so why have we seen such a massive
increase what seems like one in
shootings like this Tom Kersting is a
psychotherapist and school counselor
judge Alex rar is a former miami-dade
County judge and they both join us
tonight judge to you first we we're
gonna find out a lot more in this
specific case because unusually the
shooter is still alive but more broadly
we have seen in absolute terms a pretty
big spike in shootings like this why do
you think that is
well I mean it'd be very difficult to
just go ahead and jump into the mind of
these shooters and come up with a very
simple explanation for why they're
behaving that way
clearly society has changed in its
relationship with violence I mean I you
know I remember when I was growing up
there was nowhere near the level of
violence we have today we certainly had
guns back then but we didn't have the
level of violence we have today so I
think in some ways society has become
very desensitized to violence and I did
see back then as a police officer
parents taking a much more key role in
in educating their kids about right and
wrong we seem to have lost that line of
distinction between right and wrong not
to say that that clearly applies to this
case because nobody would ever think
that it's right to do this horrific guy
but I think like mayor Giuliani
discussed it's the little things that
lead to the big things and as a judge I
used to tell the parents and come in my
courtroom you could either discipline
your child now or somebody like me is
going to be disciplining that much later
and that discipline is going to be a lot
harder to deal with because it is a
rolling stone and once it starts moving
you know culture does change we see
culture now being very violent very I
would say desensitized to it where it
doesn't faze them anymore clearly I mean
Tom guns are are not magic they're tools
they don't operate themselves attitudes
are what matter and attitudes have
changed how have they changed do you
think well here's what I think Tucker
right so with the society we live in is
not the society I lived in growing up as
a kid this generation is being raised by
social media and smartphones and they're
not spending enough time part of the
family dynamic and the the kind of
content we see it I mean if you go on
social media whether it's just you know
the hatred from you know people's views
and so forth we see this anger and this
hatred that's occurring that's getting
into people's minds that takes someone
who's mentally
like the shooter okay imagine him
absorbing hours and hours a day of video
content which is what I would presume he
did and I think we're gonna see that I
really believe that and imagine what
that's doing to his mind alright our
actions as human beings are a reflection
of what's spinning around upstairs in
our minds so we got to get back to the
basics of families parents need to sit
down with their kids every night get
back to the dinner table and have what
the president said today deep meaningful
interactions with one another I think
that sounds right judge why isn't there
a national conversation about this it
seems like something that's important
and it's an obvious problem and people
feel like there's something deeply wrong
with the culture that would produce
something like this but there isn't a
conversation about it why I don't think
it's something you can control I think
it's a lot harder to get people to
change the way they're living their
lives than it is to say you know if we
just ban this type of gun right this
problem would go away and the reality is
that if somebody is a homicidal maniac
if somebody is and I completely agree
with the doctor that the sentiment out
there gets created especially in social
media where there's so much hatred in
today's day and age it just it becomes a
triggering effect at some point somebody
snaps so if somebody snaps and they want
to kill a lot of children because they
think you know what I'm gonna become
infamous you don't need a gun to do that
I just sitting here talking to you I can
think of three ways right now that I
could kill a lot of children if I was a
homicidal maniac and none of them would
involve guns so it's it's an easy answer
it's easy to say let's ban guns and
we've solved the problem or let's ban
this type of gun because I don't think
the US will ever having been founded
with the Wild West having been founded
with guns would ever get rid of all
their guns it's easy to say that it's a
lot harder to get people to change their
behavior in the way that they are
raising their children and especially
the way society's been kind of moving
away from religion which like it or not
did set moral parameters for people and
teach right and wrong
the other answers a lot easier yeah I
agree with that gentleman thank you both
thanks